neben mir grüße ich jetzt exklusiv auch
den organisator des fluges jaka bizilj
er ist der organisator vor cinema for
peace sie haben
herr navalny hier organisatorisch
hingeflogen und sie waren auch am
flughafen mit seiner frau als er hier in
berlin gelandet ist erzählen sie bitte
was hat sich dort abgespielt wie ist er
verbracht worden
ja sie haben es ja gerade erwähnt 80 46
47 endlich gelandet ist war eine lange
große previews odyssee
zwei tage hat hier keiner eigentlich
schlafen so eine große abenteuer wir
sind unglaublich erleichtert dass wir
nicht nur hier gelandet ist in berlin
endlich angekommen ist sondern sondern
dass auch sein zustand stabil ist selber
eine belastung sondern ein langer flug
von 56 stunden hat ihn gut überstanden
er stabil aber alle weiteren
verlautbarung zu sagen
gesundheitszustand werden halt nach und
nach immer von der charity com bzw von
seiner familie unsere mission
accomplished
wie haben sie diese rückholaktion erlebt
beschreiben sie bitte wie die deutschen
behörden sich hier mit engagiert haben
und wie geht es auch seiner frau die
seine frau ist damit dem mitgeflogen
für sie war es eine große psychische
belastung und ist konzentriert
konzentriert sich jetzt alle essen auf
die medizinischen gespräche die
vorbereitung der z ja das ganze war
insofern sehr schwierig weil man muss
also wir sind vorgestern eher zufällig
zu dem thema gekommen
bitter wäre sie doch von post und nadia
tolle konter war haben mich angerufen
weil wir vor zwei etwas ähnliches mit
ihm gemacht haben als er vergiftet
worden war
und wir haben dann am
donnerstagvormittag eben diese hilfe
also diese hilfsanfrage erhalten ich
habe zugesagt und dann in der nacht von
donnerstag auf freitag mussten wir halt
eben alles fertig bekommen die aufnahme
bestehende charité die einfach großartig
waren sofort geholfen
haben es sofort alles menschenmögliche
getan um ihn aufnehmen zu können
aber es war sehr hilfreich dass frau
merkel neben anderen staatschefs die
unterstützung zugesagt hat sollte jetzt
nicht hilfe benötigen das hier auch in
diesem lande zur verfügung stehen würde
es muss eine fluggenehmigung besorgt
werden
corona dinge beachtet werden
landegenehmigung und und uns also es war
viel komplizierter komplexer als man
gedacht hätte wobei wir davon ausging
dass wir dir nur logistisches problem
sein das du dann bis drei uhr morgens
gelöst haben und dann ging der flieger
dann am freitagmorgen
heute morgen ist hier los als allerdings
den ausgaben kamen war kein patient am
flughafen und dann wäre der flieger
normalerweise auch leer wieder
zurückgeflogen
aber die crew hatte eine ganz klare
eindeutige anweisung von mir kein
rückflug oder den patienten egal unter
welchen umständen die bleiben dort bis
der patient an bord ist und fliegen auf
gar keinen fall ohne ihn zurück das war
natürlich einfach daher gesagt wie sehr
zurückgehalten worden oder was vermuten
kann ich sofort ausführen dass die
schwierigkeit war für die crew das
flugzeug dort zu bleiben natürlich die
hatten keine wie saas also man kann
nicht einfach dort als group einen tag
da bleiben oder einfach ohne visa sich
aufhalten also kam dann zusätzliche
dinge die geklärt werden mussten
das hauptproblem war dass die russischen
ärzte darauf fast und kamen auf einmal
er wäre nicht reisefähig und wie hat
noch kein zugang zum patienten
das ging also dann wirklich den ganzen
tag mit sehr sehr vielen beziehungen
wir sprechen was auch immer
und irgendwann mal tatsächlich ein
zugang geschaffen werden konnte das
deutsche medizinische team was dann
dageblieben ist auf unsere bitte hin
tatsächlich auch zum patienten
vorgedrungen ist und dort eben ein
medical report schreiben konnte doch
dann wurde noch mal sehr kompliziert für
uns war dass man durch durchbrochen die
richtige richtung aber dann haben auf
einmal die russischen ärzte verlautbart
dass in absprache mit den deutschen
kollegen weiß oder feststellen bekommen
soll dass er nach wie vor nicht
reisefähig sei was in villingen gegen
widerspruch zu dem stand was eigentlich
unsere ärzte festgestellt haben dass er
zwar nach frischen zustand ist dass der
künstlich beatmet wird das am koma ist
aber dass das jetzt hat sich geflogen
werden kann
das risiko handelbar ist
das war daneben die nächste hürde an der
wir dann eben stundenlang weiter
arbeiten mussten
bis dann tatsächlich schon mal deinen
gestern abend das war dann 22 uhr
ortszeit die befreiende nachricht kam
dass aufgrund unseres schriftlich melden
reports in unseren deutschen ärzte team
erstellt hat
wo eben alle fakten schwarz auf weiß
belegt wurden
ein transport durch durchaus möglich ist
und daraufhin kam dann letztendlich dann
noch von russischen behörden das grüne
licht wofür wir dann auch sehr dankbar
waren hatten sie jemals das gefühl dass
ihnen da wirklich steine in den weg
gelegt werden das hat sich ja an als ob
da wirklich von außen druck aufgebaut
worden ist so dass es zu verhindern
führen so dass ich erst mal humanitäre
aktion und es wurde offensichtlich dann
gestern dass sich das dass sich das auch
zu einer politischen dimension wandelt
und dass eben nicht nur einen
medizinischen humanitären fakten an
rolle gespielt haben und es wurde
zwischenzeitlich dann eben doch sehr
politisch aber am ende dann doch wieder
humanitär medizinischen wissen froh dass
das team zugelost worden werden konnte
kurz noch ein wort zu den angehörigen zu
der frau wie haben sie das
beobachten können wie ist sie damit
umgegangen
ich denke erst wollte sie es erleichtert
ist das hier sehr gute medizinische
zustände herrschen und sie in eine das
nach wahlen jetzt in einem dafür den
kleinen häuser der welt nun
untergekommen ist die zustände in dem
hospital in omsk waren sehr schwierig
sicherlich sind dort auch kompetente
ärzte in russland aber die das skript
man die ausrüstung und die minister
möglichkeiten sind ja eine verantwortung
auch vor dem hintergrund dass gestern
nochmal ganz klar von den medizinern
festgestellt wurde hätte man seinen flug
nach moskau nicht unterbrochen diese
ermöglichen sie zwischenlandung wäre er
gestorben